hi there Steve Kaufman here um I want to
make a video in response to a video that
i received from lucas from brazil and he
posted this video in response to one of
my recent videos and i'll see if i can
somehow hook this up to this video in
some way but he says and he speaks very
good english as a young man from brazil
he says you know i enjoyed learning
english and he speaks it very well and
he studied it linked and he learned
italian and after a few weeks or months
he was doing very well but now he works
for a company in brazil that has a lot
of dealings with international companies
more customers most of whom are Spanish
speakers so he spent now a few months
using Lync and reading and listening but
he his ability to speak Spanish hasn't
improved whereas he saw remarkable
improvement in his English and his
Italian what can be the reason and I
thought that was very interesting and my
belief is without having had the chance
to really ask Lucas a lot of questions
my belief is that he's not very
motivated to speak Spanish because
Spanish is so similar to Portuguese and
very often we don't realize it that you
know we are sort of not motivated to do
some certain things this is particularly
the case with pronunciation with accents
I know that when I listen to Brazilian
Portuguese I find myself not wanting to
pronounce the T as a cha you know bong
Jia and that kind of stuff even though I
know that that that is how it's
pronounced I'm not because of maybe
because I speak Spanish and because I
listened to a lot of European Portuguese
and nor do I speak like a European
Portuguese either I sort of hung I kind
of stick with my Spanish I see myself
reluctant to let go of that Spanish
because the languages are so similar
I just want let go and and I see this
with people in their pronunciation I
mentioned another
my father who would always say Novus
cotija instead of Nova Scotia and I've
seen this with you know you'll sometimes
find learners who are native speakers of
German or of Spanish or Chinese and
they'll quote you you know proverbs
translated from their own languages in
order to explain something in English
and they think that's very good because
they like their own thing and it's
normal you you you have a certain
attachment to it's an emotional
attachment either to your own language
or say in the case of my speaking
Spanish and Portuguese I'm quite
comfortable with my Spanish
pronunciation and so to start
pronouncing essentially the same words
in quite a different way is something
that I'm at some level reluctant to do
my emotions are getting in the way
whereas if it's a totally different
language I just go for it 100% it's it's
totally make-believe imaginary I'm
playing some strange role and and so I'm
not held back so I think this can be the
case with very similar languages like if
we I speak English I could live in in
the United in Texas or Scotland for 20
years I wouldn't change how I speak I
might be slightly influenced by it but
not very much I'm comfortable with it
I'm not gonna change it whereas a
foreigner moving into those any of those
areas with it would probably be more
influenced by the local language more
trying harder wanting to imitate the
local pronunciation so I just mentioned
this because a an answer to the video
from Lucas I think that he has to try to
project himself as an Argentinian and
it's easier for him and perhaps more
attractive for him to project himself as
an Italian or an American let's say
that's fun that's positive for him he
likes doing that but yeah he doesn't
want to project themselves in
Argentinian because the Spanish are
whatever he whoever he speaks to
Paraguayan or whoever neighbors of
Brazil because
got some lovely things they should be
able to understand his Portuguese ease
he's not as motivated and I see this in
so many different areas I see this for
example where people from certain
cultures like to consider themselves
very unique and they're further
unwilling to let go of that cultural
identity that cultural ego in order to
project themselves into this other
cultural identity as I say my father you
see people even from the same language
group let's say French people and some
will pronounce English very very well
and others make no concession at all to
to English as they speak English like
this and that is the way they will only
speak it because they at some emotional
level they don't want to change so uh
you know I just want to get reaction
from people honest I think in so many
things in language learning our
willingness our emotional commitment to
our resistance to certain things our
determination our ability to project
into another persona these things are so
important so important far more
important than diagrams of the mouth and
where you put your tongue or or any
other of these artificial learning you
know tricks or tools or assists that
that you can find so I guess the the
message there is to really look at your
at your attitude and your emotional
commitment to learning a language and to
pronouncing that language you know
closer to the way it's pronounced so I
mean I I'd like to hear from Lukas I
think that's his problem I think if you
talk about learning a language what does
it mean to learn a language a Portuguese
person practically doesn't have to learn
Spanish they know 95% of the vocabulary
and the grammar is so similar that
yeah there's differences but they're not
great I mean they're basically there so
there's no reason why and I don't
believe those who say well you know
because the pronunciation is so
different you know Portuguese which has
all these diphthongs and and Spanish
which has they're very clear pure vowels
that it's more difficult for that reason
I don't think it's difficult for those
sort of technical reasons I think it's
difficult because and the proof of that
is if you listen to someone like like
Benny the Irish polyglot or Luka or
Richard simcard they pronounce each of
the Romance languages very well they
speak Portuguese very well Spanish very
well Italian very well French very well
so they are able to make all the
different sounds so the only reason a
native speaker of Portuguese Brazilian
Portuguese like Lucas is not is because
he doesn't want to I haven't heard him
an Italian but he pronounces English
very well
so it comes down to this attitudinal
thing so you know I think we can take a
lesson from that and look at how that
applies to our own language learning are
we resisting at some level are we
hanging back are we reluctant yeah
attitude is big so I look forward to
hearing your comments and maybe even
hearing from Lucas on that bye for now